one of the aspects missing in podcasts
and in this space in general is an
emphasis on the papers themselves sure
you have these four hour brobda nagyan
podcast where we go into extreme depth
minute detail however what we'd like to
do is every day even if you're not
interested in the podcast per se you'll
get a new paper 60 seconds covering a
new paper explaining the key ideas in
relatively rudimentary terms for
instance coming up will be one of the
papers that got Ed Whitson the fields
met a second one will be on Mike 11
about morphogenesis we want to cover
other papers that are obscure that would
be seminal had more people known about
them this will serve as an introduction
thus every day for 60 seconds you'll get
a Sleek new article a new paper
subscribing to toe not only gives you
podcasts but will be supplementing that
with actual hard equations and data and
charts thank you so much this is going
to be a great deal of fun